[Music]
so the final update of the resident evil
7 teaser is now available on playstation
star and james and i have jumped in and
found three new endings to the demo
we'll be uploading our playthroughs very
soon but in the meantime here is how to
get all three endings well the three
endings we know at least but that could
very well be more ending the first
ending is the same as the original demo
but this time jack has scrubbed up and
he's no longer covered in blood but for
the other two endings will be
progressing into a new area when you
wake up open the secret door by pulling
the chain in the chimney stack grab the
fuse and put it back where it belongs go
upstairs and grab the basement key from
the table and go back downstairs to this
door which is previously being locked
and has been getting a little bit more
mold each update to the demo at the end
of the corridor is the basement so use
the key there go downstairs and prepare
to be scared inside the room you'll find
one of them molded which are very
similar to the regenerators back in
ready for grab the valve and the attic
key inside this room and attempt to
leave Jackie's been a bit of a bugger
and barricades you in use the hanging
corpse to knock down the molded chap and
kick the door in back get your backside
up to the attic and climb the ladder to
freedom but wait if you've taken any
damage in the basement you will be
infected with some sort of plague or
virus and you'll pass out before you
reach freedom if you escape the basement
without taking damage you are greeted
with this text saying no one believes
you and you're high on LSD tough brick
so those are the three endings that we
found in our first hour with the game
did you find the fourth and the question
about the dummy finger continues oh and
by the way you can get a gun by using
the valve we found in the basement in
the bathroom but it doesn't seem to help
in the slightest i'm adam from
playstation grenade and i'm dying to
know what the dummy finger is for i'll
see you next time
you
you